well after he tested positive for the
coronavirus which was a scary moment and
we sent our sympathy at the time CNN's
Chris Cuomo started broadcasting his
show from his basement and from his
basement he delivered firm orders to all
Americans stay home no matter what all
right so while most Americans are
staying inside or should be right if
they're not out protesting like fools
they're not happy about being told to
stay home staying home saves lives and
the rest of us should be staying at home
for our mothers and the people that we
love and to keep us farther apart will
ultimately bring us closer together to
this cause no matter where the virus
goes the way to stop it will always be
the same our collective conscientious
actions staying home hey proles scamper
back to your hovels go inside do you
hear me at that exact moment well Chris
Cuomo was demanding that America go
inside and get back to their own homes
he wasn't taking the same advice it
turns out that at that moment he was
breaking quarantine himself despite as
we said being positive for the krona
virus one day Cohen was spotted by a
passing bicyclist who got into a tiff
with him
Cuomo attacked the man later listen I
don't want some Jack loser fat tire
biker to be able to pull over and get
him my face and in my space and talk to
me I don't want to hear it
David Whelan is the Jackass loser fat
tired biker in question the cyclist
Chris Cuomo tangled with and he joins us
tonight with his side of the story I
don't think ever had a jackass loser fat
tire bike are on the show but we're
happy to start tonight thanks so much
for coming on tell us about your
exchange with mr. Cuomo well you know
first I'd like to say I'd probably beat
him in a bike race even though he's a
lot older than me I mean younger than
but besides that the important thing was
it was Easter Sunday evening it was
chilly cold I ride I grew up about a
thousand feet from where he's building
his new house which is a nothing but a
steel frame and I did a ride and I go by
down a trail that runs past where his
new structure is being built and a bunch
of people there I've been riding for
seven eight miles take a little break
just walking and a woman says may I help
you and I said no I'm just looking and
she starts walking out a little closer
and then and there they're pretty far
away I have very good eyes and Chris
Paul motoring around and like holy
smokes is Chris Cuomo I'm fairly
outspoken and I just said don't you have
the coronavirus shouldn't you be
quarantined and I think his next words
were what the hell do you know about
this what do you know about the rules
he continued to come closer and closer
and he's I I like to say he was like a
boiling pot you could see his head just
getting getting more and more angry and
I said so you're gonna lose your temper
like you did it on the guy's Shelter
Island on me and so you know basically I
just said you have coronavirus what are
you doing out here you're supposed to be
home and I had not heard
like you just played about you know his
quotes about how he was telling people
to act I see a show occasionally and and
then at one point I said you know I'm
moving on
you know I said you're not supposed to
be out here nobody had gloves on
nobody had masks on there was three
children you know young young
adolescents and I believe there was I'm
pretty sure it's his wife because I've
seen pictures now and and then there was
a third adult so you know they're out
there they probably have cabin fever you
know like everybody that you know has
these euros in the situation has you
know and they yeah maybe maybe the hey
we have masks on we just drove out here
you know they don't live there okay it's
a steel structure and and if I probably
would just say yeah I kind of I kind of
understand I would have just moved on
but he told me he was gonna meet he was
gonna meet me and he goes you're gonna
meet me over this you will meet me again
over this and at that point he's now
getting sick forty feet away he was in
full roid rage at this point I mean he
sounds almost dangerous have you let me
I have to ask you have you been tested
because you came into contact with an
infected person who was within six feet
of you you know you know us normal human
beings we don't get to get tested you
know you know which is you know one of
the craziest things about this whole
thing you know you're wealthy you
have a lot of clouds this and that you
can go get tested but for most normal
people you can't get tested I do
practice I've made my own mask weeks ago
I hit without alcohol every day I have I
have one part-time employee I don't let
them within 10 feet of me and you know
we my daughter is a doctor at Johns
Hopkins I get lectured by her you know
forever and you know promote you know
and I yell at people when I see them you
know breaking video I cancel the last
thing you need is to get infected by a
CNN anchor who calls you a jackass loser
which by the way I don't think you are
after this conversation I think you have
a really good point and David I
appreciate your coming on tonight and I
hope you're not sick thank you backed
away when they got didn't get sick
screaming but they start getting closer
and I just said you know something and I
wasn't trying to antagonize the guy you
know and it was real simple what the
hell are you doing out here you know you
know you're on my back I think you were
wise I back away too
David thank you for coming on I really
appreciate it yeah good soon welcome